hey what's up today we're going to talk
about three tips that I have for you to
improve the overall look and feel of
your motion design to make it look that
much better so let's get started
[Music]
hey my name is Cameron with motion
science and before we get started I want
to tell you really quickly that I have a
free gift for you it's my complete guide
to mastering organic motion design and
it is a PDF download that is jam-packed
with practical tips tricks and
techniques that you can use in your
motion design every day to give it more
of an organic feel a less digital feel
it's techniques that I use in all of my
work and it's absolutely free all you
have to do is go to
motionscience.tv slash guide to download
the PDF it's
motionscience.tv guide go check it out
you will not regret it alright so let's
talk about tip number one and tip number
one is to add texture to your motion
design whenever possible I would say 95
of the time I'm able to add texture even
if it's just the slightest amount to my
motion design and it just gives it that
extra tactile feel that extra layer of
depth and dimension that really brings
about some some awesome looking motion
designs so I like to use things like
real photographs I use digital downloads
off the internet whenever I can find
chalkboard textures are a favorite of
mine paper textures paint whatever it is
anything that's tactile that I can kind
of bring into my my piece that is what
I'm going to use so let me give you just
a quick example of what I'm talking
about right here
so here we are in After Effects and I've
got this piece here that I made several
years ago it's for a main title American
Soldier and if you're interested in
picking up this this course you can
absolutely do so by going over to
aejuice.com they carry it over there now
I no longer have it here on motion
science
um so definitely go over there and check
it out but we can see there's a pretty
nice little animation I did
straightforward we see a soldier here in
the background eyes American flag lots
of texture over the top right so let me
just show you here if I just remove some
of this texture I have this flag here
you know in the soldier the soldiers got
this this ink transition that's
happening here to reveal the soldier and
it's pretty interesting stuff right I
mean it looks pretty nice but I can take
this a whole other level by adding
texture to it right and I do add texture
um in multiple layers I always pretty
much go this route so just to give an
example here I've got a cardboard
texture here that I'm going to go ahead
and turn on
and you can see it's just happening
right here in the in the bottom left
corner of the screen so if I if I solo
it and I turn it off and on it's this
this texture that's right there and I'm
going to go ahead and move down to half
res we can kind of buzz through this but
it's a moving texture that comes on
you can see it's just it's very Steppy
I'll go ahead and turn this first layer
on here
you see it's just a you know a nice
little animated texture so we've got the
soldier
transitioning on we've got this
cardboard texture and then we have that
flag here in the background right so
we've got it's already starting to look
nicer right so now if we add in the the
big flag here
that is adding this really interesting
texture over the Soldier's eyes like we
see here right so with texture and
without so you know it's it's again this
flag is is being transitioned on by an
ink footage as well if you're interested
in learning more about ink transitions I
do have a workshop over at
motionscience.tv called ink mats that
teaches exactly how I'm using them right
here
so there are the flags looking pretty
cool now the coloring because the flag
is so bright and saturated
um we do need to add some more texture
over the top some more color correction
to kind of blend it all together so now
I've got another texture here and if I
solo that one by itself this is a
favorite texture of mine it kind of
reminds me of like an album cover from
Nine Inch Nails the downward spiral
um it's just something I found on the
internet it's really interesting I like
it lay it over the top I've got another
texture here that I don't seem to know
what it's doing uh that's okay it's in
there for some reason okay so I did this
several years ago so it's it's been a
few years since I've visited this I've
got my type positioned here the type is
using a match reveal it as well and then
over the top I've got this kind of blue
texture and that is just a texture that
I blurred and if we go here we can see I
put a camera lens blur on here and if I
take that lens blur off you're going to
see that's what that texture looked like
but by blurring it right it's blown up
it's got a lot of like artifacting in it
by blurring it uh it brings some visual
interest in and then over the top of all
of that I've got these two color
correction layers
so this is the the footage the the
composition without color correction and
this is just a tritone effect which I
love tritone for color correction and
then I've got another lumetri color over
the top of that just to remove a little
bit of that green uh greenish blue from
it and leave it more of a grayish blue
and that's it right it's really simple
but you can see how much more
interesting it is versus just having
this Soldier right reveal on screen
right just
way more interesting and and the ink
mats the reason I added these is because
these are a texture in themselves right
these are these are a it's a it's a
simple transition but it's a way to also
add texture through transition so it
makes it even that much more interesting
now tip number two is to use the rule of
thirds and I I stress this all the time
in my videos and in my courses but the
rule of thirds is a game changer and
it's so easy to implement if you're not
using the rule of thirds right now you
absolutely should it's going to change
your composition so the rule of thirds
gives us interesting visual points to
look at on the screen uh to tell us
where we should be looking that it
basically tells the viewer hey look here
first then look here then look here and
then look here so let me show you what I
mean here in After Effects so if we jump
back into After Effects
um what we need to do is go and turn on
our proportional grid here and your grid
may not look like this right we've got
three squares across three squares down
now by default it's probably not going
to look at this so we're gonna go to
settings grids and guides
and we're gonna let that load up here
and then we need to make sure a
proportional grid that horizontal three
and vertical three uh that's what
they're set to I think by default
they're set to nine by nine just make
sure that they're three by three click
OK and you're gonna have a grid just
like this using the rule of thirds tells
me that certain points on the screen uh
are aligned where they should be right
so like if I look at this point up here
this top left point this is the the
first point on screen that people are
going to be drawn to and want to look at
and then it goes by second third and
fourth points maybe I got those wrong
but this is the first point I always get
confused this is a just remember that
there are very powerful points to to
focus in on right so if I have uh the
soldier the originally the soldier was
like this right
and this is okay his eyes are here in
the center but by scaling the soldier up
and making sure that his eyes are
aligned
and here on these points it makes the
composition that much more powerful to
look at so
want to make sure he's aligned there
he's looking really nice and then we've
got the flag here right so this is a
powerful point so the flag is in this
square but it's moving down here through
this point here very powerful and then
the text if you look at the text the
text is also sitting at a powerful
intersection right here now it doesn't
mean that you have to use these points
exactly as they are like the rule of
thirds is here so that you understand
how this works and then the rule is
meant to be broken so I have the text
here and now I could you know easily
move the text like up in here uh and
then you know invert it make it white so
we can see it better it could work up in
there just as well right it's very easy
it's it's powerful there it's powerful
down in here if I wanted to
kind of align a little bit more down
here you know it looks pretty good like
that too I just need to watch the um the
mat happening right there but you can
see I'm using three different points
here actually all four points I is here
I is here flag comes across this point
and the text sits on this point here and
I'm utilizing the rule of thirds to make
this composition really stand out now
tip number three is to use fluid motion
organic motion not not like mechanical
like rigid movement now some sometimes
there is a time and place for that type
of movement but for the most part in my
cinematic motion as what I call my type
of work I use very slow methodical
camera movements I think of like the
camera like if I was using a a real
world camera on this how would that
camera if you think about a cinematic
movie right the camera doesn't typically
fly all around it's it's a push in it's
a pull out it's a it's a side to side
movement it's very fluid right and I try
to use that same type of movement in my
motion design work so you're gonna see
here this is uh it's a camera that's
pulling back right the camera is pulling
going back but as it's pulling back it's
also rotating but it's a very cinematic
move right it's not like I'm not flying
around like I see a lot of motion
designs like they have their movements
and they just kind of fly all over the
screen and they're really fast and
there's no easing involved so it's
really important for me and the style
that I teach that you do have fluid
movement and you ease in and out of your
movements no jerky movements no no rigid
movements
and by doing this it creates a really
powerful scene so let's preview it here
you can see the keyframes here so the
camera
is here and it's the keyframe is
starting linear because we're we're
doing a cut into the scene so I don't
need to really ease out of this movement
I could if I wanted to but the the
camera starts uh fast and then it moves
and rotates and it comes to a slow stop
here and that's what these ease
keyframes are and I'm just using
position and rotation that's it right so
the camera is pushed in it's pulling
back but as it's pulling back it's
slightly rotating it's just a really
fluid movement now here's a pro tip for
you
and that is I have my camera parented to
a null above it right and that null its
whole movement is just to do a slight Z
rotation so you can see it's at zero
here and at the end of the composition
it's at five degrees so by parenting
that camera to that Knoll it's just
adding this extra amount of rotation the
entire time so my camera comes to an end
here but it still continues to do a
slight rotation which you can see here
because it's parented to that null so
let me show you one more quick example
here so this thing is another example of
just a very simple kind of pull back and
rotate it's not parented to a null
there's no secondary motion here I have
a course called After Effects volume 3
that teaches uh 3D cameras and lights
and layers and in that course we go deep
into
using primary controllers which is like
this camera and secondary controllers
which is like a camera being parented to
a null but you can see in this example
it's it's very simple it's a
position keyframe pulling back and it's
a rotation keyframe again and the type
is sitting in 3D space to give it some
depth and this is half resolution so it
looks a little bit pixelated just so we
can speed through this but again you can
see it's a very fluid camera movement
it's very cinematic it's very soft and
subtle and by using that it just makes
it that much more cinematic and powerful
and that is my three tips for better
looking motion design there's a lot of
other tips there but these are three
powerful ones that I always incorporate
in my work uh just a quick reminder
definitely check out my free pdf over at
motionscience.tv guide It's a complete
guide to mastering organic motion design
and it's powerful and it will change the
game for you I promise as always thanks
for watching today and I'll see you in
the next video
everything